[Musique]
dans le social installé sur sa taille
mon exploitation en tant que jeune
agricultrice depuis 2021 et mon
exploitation est essentiellement basé
sur la callas et là je m'installe
également su du production sur la
production au sol
grâce aux aides de fait à dire j'ai pu
faire ma demande pour mon projet au sol
c'est à dire pour la construction des
serre et le financement ainsi que pour
la citerne et le local
[Musique]
en fait cette installation va me
permettre justement d'avoir une
rentabilité plus importante car comme tu
l'as vu en venant on est si tu es
vraiment dans les eaux donc on pourra
faire des cycles des cas les comparer
aux séries ce qui sont dans les bas et
ça sera un gros avantage car on pourra
tomber dans la bonne période je l'espère
du moins
[Musique]
j'espère que mon exploitation sera
stabilisée qu' il y aura d'autres
projets qui vont sortir de l'eau
peut-être quelques aiguilles advani
également et pour pouvoir justement fait
un travail et locales aussi parce que la
vanille quand même un pilier pour la
région voilà